he's coming hungry food watch shadow
grows on the wall behind you swallowing
you darkness
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where every week we talk about strange
things but today we're going above and
beyond and talking about stranger things
just you wait because next year I'm
gonna go create my own show named
strangest things and one of them all
what you gonna do to beat that Netflix
create strangest is things I don't think
so
but in all seriousness Netflix is smash
hit from last year is back for Season 2
starting tomorrow and based on how
quickly people binge watch these shows
I've got like 30 hours before this
theory either gets proven 100% or gets
itself completely debunked so enjoy the
video now then come back this weekend
and laugh along with the comments and my
abject humiliation at being oh so very
wrong now for those of you who missed
season 1 because you only watch YouTube
firstly thank you for giving me a job
but secondly let me catch up on
everything you need to know to
understand today's Theory stranger
things takes place in the small town of
Hawkins Indiana way back in the 80s it's
the story of a bunch of young outcasts
who find themselves another even more
misunderstood outcasts and they all
embark on a crazy adventure together no
not that one but I do understand the
confusion
you see in stranger things the Hawkins
National Laboratory is actually a front
organization for the CIA's project
MKULTRA a very real and very bizarre
government initiative that drugged
people in an attempt to develop
mind-control techniques for use in the
Cold War sounds like a stupid plan right
and tremendously inhumane but in the
show it actually works on a young girl
named test subject 11 who acquires some
swell psychic abilities in the process
now as you can imagine being kidnapped
as a child been tortured for use as a
government tool kindness sucks and test
subject 11 escapes at the first chance
she gets
bad news therefore the CIA worst news
there for everyone else there's a
bloodthirsty monster on the loose you
see the MKULTRA experiments may just
have also created a portal to an
alternate dimension earth called the
upside down where everything is
basically the same only dead darker and
with a ton of allergens floating around
in the air so looking for some better
air quality or just an Allegra a monster
called the demagogue an escape through
the portal and goes on a killing spree
throughout Hawkins until 11 along with
her DoD buddies traps it in the town
middle school and destroys it and
perhaps herself using her mind powers
hashtag small-town problems so that's
the basic gist of season 1 but shortly
after its release one fan Theory gained
a whole lot of popularity that 11 and
the monstrous demagogue in our one in
the same ie that just like the same
buildings and locations exist in the
upside down as they do in the real world
maybe people have equivalents and the
upside down as well and that the
demagogue on is the upside down version
of L it was a good theory with some
decent evidence at the time but it
wasn't a hundred percent convincing so
with the new season on the horizon I
went in and I did a bunch of digging
myself to see what else I could find and
oh boy I think you're gonna be surprised
so that's the plan for today review the
existing evidence suggesting the
connection as well as the additional
hints clues and science I've been able
to find that support the idea then cover
the huge hint that exists in the season
two trailers and what started as an
interesting idea becomes a convincing
theory by the end of the day so grab
your favorite breakfast snack of choice
and let's begin
hey except for that one leggo my eggo
first the existing evidence the theme of
duality is everywhere and stranger
things i mean look no further than the
upside down itself it's a dark version
of earth where everything has a mirror
image that's a pretty darn obvious then
there's the episode one reference to
x-men comic number 134 aka the start of
the Dark Phoenix saga in which Jean Grey
a powerful psychic mutant becomes an
even more powerful and to be known as
the Phoenix the story goes that Jean
eventually develops an evil alter ego
known as The Dark Phoenix becoming a
superpower in villain that the x-men
must unite to defeat at the end of the
series Jean Grey sacrifices herself to
save her friends it's an interesting
choice of comic considering that 11 a
psychic might just have an evil
counterpart that she too sacrifices
herself to defeat in order to save her
friends parallels I think so given the
choice of calling this Mario piranha
plant reject monster the named Emma
Gorgon supports this theory as we see in
the opening minutes of episode 1 the
demagogue in is an actual monster from
the real-life game of Dungeons & Dragons
for those who don't know since its first
appearance back in 1976 the demagogue
has remained one of DN DS most iconic
monsters and although a few things about
it have changed over the years
whew design features have always stayed
consistent specifically the monsters two
heads sharing one body one head
represents deception and lies and the
other is madness and insanity they are
themselves a duality it's also canon
according to Dungeons & Dragons 3rd
edition that both heads are secretly out
to destroy each other so you have two
connected heads that are trying to
destroy each other sounds kind of like
Ellen the monster two connected entities
that are trying to kill one another even
the themes of the two heads connect to
these characters l would be associated
with deceptions and lies because she's a
product of a government cover-up she was
kidnapped she was used the monster
meanwhile seems to lack all rational
thought it's drawn like an animal to the
central blood it kills indiscriminately
it's an entity of madness that lashes
out and everything including Elevens
creator dr. Brenner which by the way is
an interesting scene that to my
knowledge no one has picked apart yet
when the monster appears at the school
at the climax of the show it doesn't go
after the people who are literally
shooting at it with automatic machine
guns it makes a beeline straight for dr.
Brenner Levin's so called a father who
spent his life torturing her as a part
of MKULTRA up until this point in the
show the monster had been attacking
anything and everything with abandoned
so why here is it selecting its target
and why specifically Brenner he only
makes sense if 11 is the demagogue and
embodying her madness her rage that's
how the monster knows him it has a
personal connection to him through L it
kills him because that's what L would
love to do to Brenner but perhaps most
blatantly of all are the parallels that
happen in the final moments of the
season first the demagogue in raises its
hand just as L finishes him off L raises
her right arm and the monster for no
reason
does the same right before it disappears
they are literally mirroring each other
and when the monster disappears so does
11:11 even says that she is the monster
monster coincidence
obviously not oh yeah and all of this is
without me even mentioning the fact that
L is the reason the monster comes to
Hawkins to begin with she comes into
contact with him during one of her
telepathy sessions which is what opens
the rift the demagogue and escapes
through if
that doesn't seal it for you I don't
know what we'll actually yes I do
because I have even more evidence to
thrown in this pile one element most
recaps of this theory overlooked is how
11 and this Pan's Labyrinth wannabe
share the exact same power set and I say
the exact same powers I mean the exact
same powers we see multiple times near
the end of the season that one of 11s
powers is to access the upside down from
the real world without crossing over she
uses this ability most frequently to
speak with the missing boy will buyers
the monster is also able to do this
either fully or partially crossing over
whenever and wherever it feels like even
in the original planning phases for the
series it was clear that 11 and the
monster were meant to be parallels of
each other in the original pilot script
people would bleed from their nose and
ears when in contact with the demagogue
and similar to how 11 bleeds from her
nose and sometimes her ears when using
her telekinetic powers even science
supports the connection between the two
characters throughout season 1 we see
that when 11 has to push her powers to
their limits like when attempting
psychic communication between worlds the
electricity of the surrounding area
flickers or just goes completely out
it's the exact same effect that the
demagogue in has on electricity whenever
he's close and surrounded by electric
lights it always causes everything to
flicker this electric potential is also
something we see come across in the
interdimensional phone calls that happen
in the series Will's mother Joyce
repeatedly gets phone calls from her son
and upside down calls that get cut off
when the monsters near and the calls
always end with an electrical shock
again showing his electric potential
convinced no come on I mean at this
point even the characters think she's
the monster do you ever stop to think
that maybe she's the monster fine fine
be a stickler then the biggest clue that
absolutely proves the connection between
11 and the monster is something that
we've all known about since the very
first episode of the series and
something that has been very consciously
reinforced in the season two trailers in
the beginning of episode 1 the monster
shows that it's able to unlock wills
door telepathically look at how the
director frames the shot and shows the
monster clearly
to slide the door line and throughout
season one we see how Elle's able to
perform similar telekinetic tricks like
making the Millennium Falcon float
flipping a car and opposite of the
monster locking a door so that already
shows that both she and the monster
possess telekinesis but I think the
creators of the show are hinting at a
little bit more than that
here's the key moment in the season 2
trailer I'm referring to we see 11
running through the woods before getting
a close-up of a sliding door lock just
like the one we saw at the very
beginning of season 1 and just like
before it slowly slides until it unlocks
but this time we're assuming it's being
done by L because it's the middle of the
day and we just saw her running the show
is giving us a direct parallel between
the actions of the monster and the
actions of L which means either the
monster isn't dead or at this point L is
the monster you've got to be convinced
right that names the powers the parallel
scenes the pop-culture references even
the science everything points to them
being one in the same and that has huge
implications for the story remember like
the lure of the demagogue game as long
as one head exists the other remains
locked in this eternal struggle to
destroy each other and as we can see L
is certainly a part of this season which
means we may not be done with the demo
Bornu and won't be until l chooses to
sacrifice herself this time for good or
alternatively she's just the monster now
could definitely be that or option 3 the
new season has literally nothing to do
with any of this
that's probably the one who'll end up
being but hey oh wait even the number 11
reads the same forwards and backwards
right side up and upside down boom done
Mike dropped but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cut what some
more stranger things or maybe just more
of me being a goofball well in either
case you're in luck because I'm hosting
a new show in partnership with Amazon
fire TV called
where I get you up to speed on all the
must watch biggest shows that are
streaming in less time than it takes to
toast your Eggo waffles so far I've
covered transparent Curb Your Enthusiasm
and of course
stranger things but other big-name
titles are on the way including
Westworld which I've done a theory about
here on the channel so if you want to
know what's worth watching or just want
to get caught up without having to watch
the whole series from the beginning or
heck you just want to spend a bit more
time with my lame jokes and Ronnie's
cartoon recreations of some of
entertainments biggest names right now
then check out couch land on Amazon fire
TV channel link is in the description or
better yet just click the annotation you
see on screen right about now or in a
few seconds for now they can only appear
with 20 seconds left on the video each
episode is like three minutes long so go
over there and tell a matpat sense yeah
seriously please do it will make me look
really good to Amazon if you just flood
their comments section with how excited
you are to have more matpat in your life
in fact you can even do this go over
there and comment Matt Pat is so blank
I want to blank obviously you replace
the blanks with funny words or don't
whatever now go watch stream and enjoy
and now if you'll excuse me I need to
keep refreshing Netflix so I can just
marathon my way through season 2 see you
on the flip side or should I say the
upside down side whatever just click and
I'll see you next week